the other thing that we discussed in the
last lecture was a classification of the
different states of a Markov chain in
two different types a Markov chain in
general are states that are recomment
which means that from that recurrent
state you can go somewhere else and then
fund that somewhere else you can always
come back to it so if you have a Markov
chain of this form and you start in
state 9 the options for you is to either
go to state 3 or to state 5 but no
matter what if you go to 3 you can come
back always and if you go to 5 you can
always come back as well so clearly 9
here will be a recurrent State and 3 for
the same reason and 5 as well now if you
look at the state 6 or 7 it is the same
thing starting from 6 the only way that
you can go to is either stay at 6 so go
to 7 and then in that case you always
come back and same thing from 7 you can
either go to 6 and that's it actually
and come back so both of these are
recurrent as well so in a case a state
is not recurrent we will call it
transient so let's look at for example
state 1 from state 1 if you go from 1 to
2 and then go to 6 there is no way to
come back to 1 so the state 1 is
transient and for the same reason the
state 4 will be transient in the state 2
will be transient what about 8 well the
same reason the state is transient as
well so what we have seen also is the
notion of a recurrent class a recurrent
class is again a collection of recurrent
states that can communicate between each
other so here for this specific example
we have two classes this is one class
all right so it's a class one all right
let's call it recurrent class one and
this is a recurrent class recurrent
class two so here again we have two
classes instead of one because if you
are in one of this class
there is no way that you can find a path
to go to one state here and vice versa
if you are in one of these states here
there is no path that would lead you to
that way current class now in the case
where you have two recurrent classes
like here or more it is pretty clear
that in the long run the steady-state
behavior of the Markov chain will really
depend on where you started so for
example if your Markov chain started in
that recurrent class there is no
probability that in the long run it will
be in that class and vice versa is
stored here the priority of being in
that wreckin class in the long run is
zero so the long run behavior of the
Markov chain will depend on the initial
condition in the case where you have
only one recurrent class let's forget
about that portion for example and we
have only that portion here then maybe
the initial condition will not matter in
the long run but in fact it's not going
to be always the case running on the
recurrent class being periodic or not as
we will see in the next clip